the death of a beloved actor can be
quite devastating especially one who was
on a Nickelodeon show you grew up
watching sadly these actors are no
longer with us actor and comedian Les
Lyle began his career on television back
in the early 1970s and later became a
major part of you can't do that on
television the children's sketch comedy
series in which you played numerous
characters alongside an ensemble cast of
kids the show initially aired on local
television in Canada before switching to
a national format that was broadcast on
CTV Nickelodeon then picked up the
series and took a more active role in
production as it became a ratings hit in
the United States it'll be more of this
studying and none of you will be allowed
to stay for detention after school Lyle
appeared on every season of you can't do
that on television for a total of 144
episodes during that time he continued
to perform in other kids shows including
voicing characters on animated series
such as Dennis the Menace and the
adventures of Teddy Ruxpin Lyle passed
away in Ottawa Canada in 2009 at the age
of 84. no cause of death was publicly
provided by his agent or family
Makoto iwomatsu most commonly credited
throughout his career as Mako was a
Japanese American actor who had roles in
a large number of Television projects
and films he received an Academy Award
nomination for his performance in the
Sand Pebbles 1966 and had iconic roles
in the Conan the Barbarian franchise
Samurai Jack and Dexter's Laboratory for
Nickelodeon Mako had several parts in
the highly acclaimed animated series
avatar The Last Airbender most notably
the fire-breathing Master iro the mentor
aide and Uncle to the fire nation's
Prince Zuko Mako also had a brief role
as Mr Yamaguchi a fun-loving CEO of the
toy company that invented Reptar in
2000's Rugrats in Paris the actor died
in his home in Somas California in 2006
from esophageal cancer he was 72 years
old and still working up until the end
the character iro and Avatar would be
recast with Greg Baldwin for the final
two seasons of the show and for the
sequel series The Legend of Korra
Christine Cavanaugh had a long acting
career making her debut as a voice actor
in the late 1980s she appeared in a
single episode of Cheers before having
her first Nickelodeon appearance in two
episodes of Salute Your Shorts she would
go on to voice the character oblina and
ah real Monsters and the adorably
nervous Chucky Finster in the Rugrats
franchise I don't know maybe it's not
such a good idea also known for her
roles in both the 1995 Academy
award-nominated film babe and the
Cartoon Network animated series Dexter's
Laboratory Kavanaugh retired from acting
in 2001 with Bart Simpson voice actor
Nancy Cartwright replacing her as Chucky
and Rugrats she would pass away 13 years
later at her home at the age of 51
although no official cause of death was
released she had been diagnosed with
leukemia after making his acting debut
in a music video for the singer and
actress JoJo Cody Longo Rose to fame for
his part in the 2012 Nickelodeon drama
series Hollywood Heights aimed at an
older audience compared to other
Nickelodeon shows it largely focused on
the exploits of Brittany Underwood's
Lauren as she comes into contact with
rock star Eddie Duran Longo played Eddie
in 78 of these series's 80 episodes
outside of Nickelodeon he had recurring
roles in make it or Break It and secrets
and lies with his final appearance
coming in the podcast High School crimes
and misdemeanors in 2020. he had
simultaneously worked in music as a
singer and producer throughout many
stages of his career in 2023 Longo was
discovered having passed away in his
home in Austin Texas his representative
suggested that he had died in asleep
from an accidental alcohol overdose
Kurt Bailey had roles in seemingly
everything from NYPD Blue to Hotel
Transylvania her Nickelodeon Bailey is
best known for his performance as Kevin
Lee the bossy camp counselor who's
constantly pranked in all 26 episodes of
the two season comedy series Salute Your
Shorts while the character Kevin
desperately wants to command others
respect and admiration the kids at Camp
I don't want to hold him at such low
esteem they routinely call him Ugg to
his face because he's ugly
ugly
before his death in 2022 he was credited
with additional voices in The SpongeBob
Movie sponge on the Run pause the fury
the legend of Hank and an episode of
Love death and robots he was 59 years
old when he died of lung cancer
Jensen Panettiere is probably best known
for his work in films but the actor also
appeared in a number of Nickelodeon and
Disney Channel shows and made for TV
movies his first role came in 2002 on
the television series Even Stevens
before he managed to snag small parts
and Hope and Faith and Third Watch he
claimed to roll alongside his sister
Hayden Panettiere in the Disney Channel
film tiger cruise and provided the voice
of Truman ax on Nickelodeon's animated
show the exes he later portrayed the
main character in the 2007 Nickelodeon
television movie The Last Day of Summer
reports of Panettiere's death came in
February of 2023 when his body was found
at his home in New York City it was just
28 when he passed away and the cause of
death was later revealed to be
cardiomegaly the actor had an enlarged
heart and aortic valve complications
among the most famous voice actors was
John alaski best known as Mel blanc's
replacement for a variety of Warner
Brothers characters including Bugs Bunny
Daffy Duck and Sylvester cat Pulaski
also worked on a number of Nickelodeon
projects portraying Mermaid Man in two
of the SpongeBob SquarePants video games
as well as providing a voice for a
season 4 episode of Hey Arnold but
alaski is probably best known for his
role as Grandpa Lou pickles and Rugrats
who replaced original actor David Doyle
in 1997 and continued to portray Grandpa
Lou in the television show and several
movies until 2006. in 2016 the actor
passed away at the age of 63 in his home
in New York his spokesperson confirmed
that at the time he had been diagnosed
with cancer his final voice performance
came in 2016's Tom and Jerry Back to Oz
many people might not immediately
recognize Steve vixton but that might be
because he has primarily worked as a
writer his first writing credit for a
television series came when he
co-authored 15 episodes of Rugrats and
went on to write for duck man private
dick Family Man recess and co-created
and co-developed the series Hey Arnold
and addition to his extensive behind the
scenes work on this late 90s Nickelodeon
animated series vixton also voiced
several recurring characters the most
notable among them being Oscar kokaska I
wanted to do something to help you with
your play so I made Susie write all your
lines on these tiny pieces of paper big
's final writing credit came in 2011 on
an episode of The Simpsons in 2014 at
the age of 53 the writer and voice actor
died no official cause of death was ever
publicly released Craig Bartlett paid
tribute to his former Hey Arnold writer
saying today Arnold is hatless as I
remember Steve this was in reference to
the first Hey Arnold script that gave
vixton Soul credit the episode titled
Arnold's hat
Alice playton was an actor arguably best
known for her voice work though she also
played live-action roles in films like
2009's The Rebound in 1985's Legend as
well as television shows like Frazier
and Law and Order she got her first role
on stage at the age of 11 and was later
nominated for a Tony Award but her most
famous voice acting gig was arguably
playing while the heiress BB Bluff and
Nickelodeon's animated series Doug and
she would reprise the role in Doug's
first movie throughout the run of the
show Clayton also occasionally provided
the voice for other minor characters
news arose in 2011 that she had died in
her home borough of Manhattan in New
York City her cause of death was heart
failure brought on by a mix of June
diabetes and pancreatic cancer
Fred Willard was best known for his
comedy work fans would likely recognize
him from Mrs spinal tap Anchorman the
Legend of Ron Burgundy Roseanne and
Everybody Loves Raymond in more recent
times he played Frank Dunphy in Modern
Family a performance that earned him two
Primetime Emmy nominations is here we
bear
Phil since we
it's always a Wanderer it's the curse of
being a genius for Nickelodeon Willard
voice the character Sammy Redman in a
single episode of Hey Arnold and the
loud grandfather pop pop in four seasons
of the still running series the loud
house whether it's death at the age of
86 was first reported in May of 2020.
his daughter hope paid tribute to her
father stating he kept moving working
and making us happy until the very end
it was later revealed that Willard had
died from Cardiac Arrest due to
complications from coronary artery
disease
Robin Griggs will be most familiar for
her roles in the soap operas One Life to
Live in another world as well as the
small budget horror films of her later
career like hell week and slasher's gone
wild the actor's time on Nickelodeon
came on the show rated K for kids by
kids where she was one of a handful of
hosts during the 1988 season the series
primarily focused on raiding new movies
and discussing their positives and
negatives it became part of an essential
experimental phase for the network
mostly known at the time for the game
show double dare Griggs died at 49 years
old in 2022 after being diagnosed with
endocervical adenocancer she had spent
much of the final stage of her life
discussing her condition on social media
first rising to prominence and soap
operas like Days of Our Lives In Another
World Police sampler became a prolific
voice actor who played characters in
many animated projects such as Lucky
Star Digimon Digital Monsters and the
theatrical film Demon Slayer Infinity
train
sampler also appeared in a number of
Nickelodeon shows over the years
including a 1997 Rugrats episode and the
2019 installment of the loud house but
her best known Nickelodeon voice role
might be her Legend of Korra character
top bayfon an earth-bending Master first
introduced an avatar The Last Airbender
the actor died of a heart attack in 2021
she had been voicing characters in the
French animated series miraculous Tales
of ladybug and Cat Noir before she died
at the age of 67.
Rick Burson was a prolific voice actor
who worked in franchises like Star Wars
and Looney Tunes having trained with
Dawes Butler the voice behind characters
like Yogi Bear and Huckleberry Hound
Burson took over many of Butler's roles
following his death in 1988. a year
later Burson was also chosen as one of
the replacements for the legendary Mel
Blanc lending his voice to the likes of
Elmer Fudd and many other Looney Tunes
characters as a Nickelodeon voice actor
he portrayed characters in both the
Angry Beavers and cat dog but in 2004
his career came to an abrupt end after
he was arrested at his home in Tujunga
Los Angeles following a standoff with
police reports of the incident offer
conflicting details but it seemed that
he was armed heavily intoxicated and
possibly threatening a female roommate
on the morning of his arrest Burson died
four years later at the age of 59.
according to Mark avenir who had
previously worked with the actor on
several projects his death was in part
due to diabetes and arterial sclerosis
also claiming quote drinking had a lot
to do with it
Tara Carrera McMullen began her acting
career in 2004 when she was cast in the
basketball comedy rebound despite having
no acting experience Carrero McMullen
was recommended for the part by her
mother who was working as a casting
agent she then landed a recurring role
in the CBS legal drama Judging Amy where
she played the gang member gracelia
Reyes before making a single appearance
in the Nickelodeon comedy series Zoe 101
at just 16 years old the young actor was
killed while standing outside her
apartment complex in 2005. according to
police she was shot during gang-related
violence that also wounded two of her
friends two individuals were later
sentenced to life in prison without
parole for the shooting
[Music]
thank you